the vision of Tencent is to connect
people and connect everything we build
our product by industry which means we
have a smart game cloud-like smart
ecommerce smart internet a lot of
enterprise customers come to us and you
know they won't get help from pencil and
pizza cloud you know all over the world
people will ask for IBM consulting IBM
cloud and now I think maybe IBM can
bring us to this enterprise world so we
can work together to change this kind of
enterprise view so that means they will
put a lot of effort a research and
determine the cloud strategy how to
serve their customers how do they help
their customers to grow on cloud if we
put our product until IBM cloud for the
customers they are they have the same of
the experience and they can extend it to
any other regions that IBM Khan has I
believe that if we can announce that we
work with IBM at an oppressed level the
companies will be convinced that we can
deliver a more comprehensive solutions
for them together with IBM because now
you know how to change everything
especially now I think maybe most of the
gaming internet mobile apps a
cloud-based and the last an important
part is enterprise how we can use in
Tencent knowledge about the Internet
together with IBM's knowledge about
enterprise compare them together there
with a new revolution
[Music]